IFM  -- I’M SANDRA SMITH.
>> Trace: I’M TRACE GALLAGHER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLING THE
PROPOSAL UNSCIENTIFIC BUT
PUBLIC OPINION APPEARS TO BE IN
BIDEN.
MORE THAN 70% OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT A REQUIREMENT TO WEAR A
MASK OUTSIDE THE HOME.
>> Sandra: JACKIE IS REPORTING
LIVE FOR US THIS MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SANDRA,
GOOD MORNING, TRACE.
16 STATES CURRENTLY DON’T HAVE
STATEWIDE MASK MANDATES.
ALL OF THEM RUN BY REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
WAS TALKING TO THEM WHEN HE
CALLED ON GOVERNORS TO ENACT A
NATIONWIDE MASK MANDATE.
>> THE ESTIMATES BY THE EXPERTS
ARE IT WILL SAVE OVER 40,000
LIVES IN THE NEXT THREE MONTHS.
40,000 LIVES.
IF PEOPLE ACT RESPONSIBLY.
AND IT’S NOT ABOUT YOUR RIGHTS,
IT’S ABOUT YOUR
RESPONSIBILITIES AS AN AMERICAN.
>> WHITE HOUSE REACTION WAS
SWIFT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID BIDEN IS
POLITICIZING THE PANDEMIC AND
DEFENDED HIS ADMINISTRATION’S
APPROACH OF URGING PEOPLE TO
WEAR MASK WHILE FOCUSING THE
WORK OF THE GOVERNMENT ON
THERAPEUTICS AND VACCINES BUT
SUGGESTED WHAT HE IS ASKING IS
DRACONIAN BIG GOVERNMENT.
>> President Trump: HE WANTS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES WITH THE MERE STROKE OF
A PEN TO ORDER FOR CITIZENS TO
WEAR A MASK FOR A MINIMUM OF
THREE STRAIGHT MONTHS.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAS THE
UNILATERAL POWER TO ORDER EVERY
CITIZEN TO COVER THEIR FACE
WHAT OTHER POWERS DOES HE HAVE?
>> BACK IN JUNE BIDEN SUGGESTED
HE WOULD USE EXECUTIVE POWER AS
PRESIDENT TO MANDATE MASKS IN
PUBLIC.
YESTERDAY HE DID NOT SAY HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ENACT A
FEDERAL MANDATE FOR MASKS OR
CALL ON THE WHITE HOUSE TO
ENACT ONE.
HE CALLED ON STATES TO TAKE THE
LEAD.
KAMALA HARRIS DISCUSSED
TESTING, TRACING AUND FUNDING
OF VACCINES.
IT COMES AFTER A NEW FOX NEWS
POLL SHOWS A MAJORITY OF VOTERS
IN EVERY PARTY FAVOR REQUIRING
MASK AND HALF THINK THE FEDERAL